foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
biofluid-based biomarkers for
neurological disease
I am Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by biotechnique to learn more visit
bio-technie.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I would now like to welcome our speakers
PhD assay development manager at
biotechnique
Dr High retin tumani scientist and
professor at ohm University Hospital
Department of Neurology
and Dr Stefan halbergower postdoctoral
researcher University hospital
um
Department of Neurology Institute for
experimental neurology
pass it over to you to get us started
you may now begin your presentation
thank you so much Kaylee and thank you
everyone for joining us today so
um I'll start right ahead considering we
have a lot to cover today my talk as you
can see in the title uh has to do with
Precision biomarker detection and
specifically I'm going to focus on how
an automated immunoassay platform can
really uh push the boundaries of
biomarker detection
so before going into biomarkers just a
few words about our company biotechnic
as you can see in this graphic uh there
are quite a few products and product
lines uh under the roof of biotechnic
anything from Elisa kids proteins
antibodies instruments and many other
Technologies and really the overarching
theme is to empower research Empower
research
or for clinical Diagnostics by providing
the robust tools and I hope that the
presentation today will help serve as a
kind of a demonstration of that to a
certain degree
so let's jump right on to uh biomarkers
so biomarkers have many different
definitions the definition that you see
here on the screen is a very narrow one
but it's I think suitable for today's
talk in the sense that you can think of
biomarkers in the uh realm of of
biofluids as any protein or even a
molecule that can inform us on the
physiological state of its donor
um when we uh think about biomarkers in
the neurological space uh and
specifically about biomarkers in
biofluids there's been a lot of research
recently both in Blood and in CSF and
you can already think about the utility
that biomarkers may have for diagnosis
prognosis and treatment or evaluating
the efficacy of treatment across
multiple neurological diseases
so rather than going uh deep into that
that will be covered in the rest of the
talks in this webinar what I'd like to
talk today about is how how do we detect
and how do we measure biomarkers in
biological fluids
um looking at you know Decades of
History I think one of the most common
methods to quantify
biomarkers and biological fluids is
Elisa Eliza is a method where that
utilizes antibodies that are specific to
the molecule in question you can see
here in this example typical microplate
are coated with capture antibody
and the capture antibody can as the name
suggests capture and bind to the analyte
of Interest
then in this particular example we see
what we call sandwich Eliza where it's
secondary antibody and detection
antibody is bound to the analyte from
another site and the detection antibody
is bound to a reporter molecule that
essentially what it does is emits light
either through chemiluminescence or
fluorescence and that light is
correlated directly to the concentration
of the analyte in the sample so it can
tell us
the quantitative measure of this analyte
in the fluid
so as you can see here this is a widely
used method right 12 000 Publications
per year it's been around for over 50
years now and as most of us can imagine
any method but definitely a method
that's been around for so long uh does
come with some drawbacks
so what are the drawbacks of uh Eliza uh
for anyone who has performed it uh you
can easily tell that is quite an annual
could be laborious it's several hours of
work a lot of washing of the plate
tapping applying reagents applying
antibodies washing again and so on and
so forth uh for that reason it is quite
difficult to scale it up to large
amounts of samples and for the same
reason also it creates variability right
different users might do it slightly
different you can also have a chance for
human error introduced during this uh
multiple steps
um another issue with Eliza that may
arise is the fact that many of the
Allies out there are non-steritized so
if you think about your favorite analyte
and you want to measure it there might
be quite a few protocols out there quite
a few Liza's antibody pairs some of them
are fully validated some are not so it
becomes really difficult to compare
across labs and across sites
and lastly Eliza could be wasteful
um some of the biofluids that we're
interested in could be quite precious uh
imagine for example CSF from uh a
disease donor
um so we want to be very mindful in how
much volume of that sample we use and we
want to preserve it as much as possible
so for these reasons you know uh we
thought uh we would like to to think
about a little differently
and what I'm going to show you here is
Ella Ella is a microfluidic or fully
automated platform that performs this
amino acid in a closed system
if you look at the right you will see uh
what it means from an investigator
perspective
from the experimental perspective uh
what you do with Ella is you take a
cartridge you can see it on the right
with multiple Wells
you need to scan a barcode you add your
samples you add wash buffer and you
insert it into the Ella device
and all the rest happens completely
automatically all the rest is hands-free
within 90 minutes since the beginning of
the experiment you will get your results
and on the left side you can see a whole
bunch of
um advantages that come with this
platform and the reason is mostly due to
the fact that it's fully automated right
because it's fully automated you
eliminate the user or the human aspect
of of the assay uh there are also other
advantages we have to do that have to do
with the microfluidic design of the
platform so rather than going one by one
here on this checklist I'd actually go
ahead and simply demonstrate some of
these principles
so how does it work what you're seeing
here is a typical cartridge
for Ella it's a little bit different
than the cartridge that you just saw in
the previous slide and the reason is
these cartridges come in different
formats some of them allow for 16 uh
samples some of them can allow for more
and that adds to the variability and the
versatility of the platform in this case
we have a cartridge where you can apply
up to 16 different samples and each one
of them will be measured in uh
across four different analytes so if we
flip that cartridge and if we look at
the bottom you will see a micro
microfluidic circuit
quite small and this microfluidic
circuit which which I'll zoom into has
those very very tiny three little dots
if you can see which are now highlighted
here they look like dots but they're
actually nanotubes um there are glass
nanotubes which we call gnrs Glass Nano
reactors and this is really where the
so-called magic happens right so if you
look into the GNR
which is depicted here on the left the
tube
um you will see that the GNR is coated
with capture antibody a sample will
throw through this tube and the Elisa
will take place inside this GNR in a
completely automated manner you can also
see on the right that there are three
gnrs for each Channel meaning each
analyte will be measured in triplicates
within the microfluidic circuit
so let's take an even deeper dive into
how it works
so what you're seeing here is a
representation of a GNR within a
microfluidic circuit this sample just
flew into
the various channels you can see that in
Gray and again everything that I'm
depicting here basically happens
automatically within the script of the
device so once the analyte is inside the
sample is inside the GNR
it will be a slot back and forth
which you can see here and the analyte
will bind to its specific capture
antibody
then what we need to do is to remove all
the excess protein which is being done
by a series of
um
flashes of wash buffer which is in the
cart
and the next step would be to apply the
detect antibody in this case because the
cartridge has four different Allied
analytes they are depicted in four
different colors here and pay attention
to the fact that through a series of
valves we can completely isolate those
different channels from each other so
that the detect antibodies for one
analyte will not interfere or interact
with detect antibodies for a different
analyte this really adds to the
robustness of the platform by avoiding
cross-reactivity across
antibodies so here's the secondary
antibody binding and creating the
sandwich with the analyte it is
Flushed Away
and the next step would be
to apply to die
the dye is fluorescently tagged it will
bind to the detect
will washed away
and finally
the last step would be a laser that is
existing within the device will
stimulate stimulate stimulate and uh
result in emitting light from the
fluorescent fluorophores this will be
measured by the device and the last
thing that you will see will be the
results right so this just uh it's the
last step of the Ella run and as you can
see here what you get immediately is all
the information that you need you will
get three readings for each analyte and
you will get the actual concentrations
and the reason that you can get the
actual concentrations without any need
of calculation or fitting curves is
because standard curve is embedded
within the cartridge this helps both
standardizing the assay as well as
making it simple and fast for you to use
um and also if you look here at the
column with the CVS coefficient of
variance you can see that the
coefficient of variances are typically
very low on a single digit and that is
again due to the microfluidic and
automatic nature of the device
so so far I've shown you how this can
make life easier right simpler you don't
need to wash you don't need to do all
these multiple steps in a manual manner
but there are many more advantages to
using this platform
um
on a microfluidic
setting uh what you can see here on the
left is a comparison of two standard
curves that were obtained with the Ella
in blue compared to a traditional Liza
in Orange and the first thing that you
notice is that the Ella has a much
better sensitivity and dynamic range
compared to a traditional Elisa this is
something that we see across many
analytes and across our assays and it
really helps making a difference because
in this case you can see how samples
which are depicted uh with the blue and
the orange circles are detectable on one
platform on the Ella but are below
detectable threshold for the other
this is actually being verified uh in a
clinical setting
or at least with clinical samples
and this is what you're seeing here on
the right
on the very right column healthy you can
see the il-6 which is interlooking six
very low abundance protein distributed
across many donors around one two three
picogram per milliliter note the
logarithmic scale on the y-axis
but if you look at uh patients for
example prostate cancer patients on the
left usually these values can go all the
way to 1000 and over picogram per
milliliter and because the dynamic range
is wide for Ella you don't have to worry
about it you just apply your sample the
same dilution and you will get the
results either high or low they will be
reliably quantifiable by the device
another perhaps even more
um
perhaps even more
obvious way of thinking about the
advantages of an automatic microfluidic
platform is the notion of increased
Precision right so in this slide you can
see how um
the same sample this is a neurofilament
light as actually we'll talk a lot about
this during this webinar the same sample
was uh prepared many many times and run
across multiple sites in this case three
sites and you can see how the
distribution of these samples across
sites no matter where they were used by
run by the same user or the different
cartridges or on a different Ella
machine the Precision is high the
coefficient of variance here is below 10
which is quite good for an inter-assay
precision and this is something again
that we see across assays and across
analytes
so Ella has currently over 250 validated
assays which are available on those
multiple um
Outreach formats you can see here on the
lower uh left side uh the various
research areas that these assays um are
involved in anything from inflammation
ecology Nephrology neuroscience and
various other fields and when we look
into the Neuroscience some of the
existing assays are neurofilament-like
neurofilament heavy we have a gfap assay
for CSF samples and uh we're quite happy
to announce that amyloid data 140 and
142 have just been validated and they
will be available
in April 2023 we're also working on
several other analytes uh Tau phosphatal
neurogranin gfap in steroid plasma and
various other assays so stay tuned for
that
lastly
um we also have many over accessories
including the interlookings and
cytokines
um validated in CSF so for those who are
interested in neuroinflammation studies
um some of these assays are already
fully validated in CSA if you don't have
to do any extra work on your end to make
sure that they can work for that sample
type
so uh with a minute or two that I have
left I just wanted to highlight uh one
or two essays that we have on our
platform one of them will talk a lot
about during this webinar so I will go
very briefly over this is the
neurofilament
uh and we have neurofilament heavy
neurofilament light assays available in
Ella they're pretty widely used
um here on the left side you can see a
demonstration of how they can be
utilized in ALS patients both in serum
and CSF you can see the pretty Market
increase in neurofilament light uh
with ALS patients
um we've seen a lot of usage of these
Assets in the past several years the NFL
and if HR States had 22 25 period
Publications just in the last year more
coming out this year they are very
useful to detect a neural injury
across various neurological conditions
and just to go over a few highlights
from very recent Publications to those
for those interested uh there has been a
two 2023 paper
um a commutability study with quite a
few uh researchers in the field that
combined uh forces if you will and uh
tested NFL assays across multiple
platforms including Ella including other
platforms that you might know all link
simoa Siemens and uh yeah I encourage
everyone to read those are interested I
encouraged to read this paper and to
appreciate the high reproducibility that
these assays have across platforms
uh there have been also several
um direct comparisons over Ella assays
with other platforms such as simoa so
this is on the right side and
um more are mentioned here at the bottom
so
um feel free to read those as well if
that's your interest
so to conclude
um
what my presentation hopefully was
trying to show is that using an
automated immunoassay Solutions we can
increase precision robustness and the
sensitivity of assays across analytics
and biomarkers uh the automated
automated nature of the device help
accelerate workflow increase throughput
and avoid the user introduced
variability that is inherent to Eliza
applications and finally several
Neuroscience biomarkers on Ella can uh
really uh provide the required
sensitivity and utility for biomarket
research across neurological conditions
and they could be also combined with
additional assays on Ella menu
so I will stop here and I'd like to
thank you all for your attention and
um I'll be happy to answer any questions
during the Q a session thank you
thank you joab before we get started
with our next speaker I'd like to invite
the audience to participate in a poll
question here so you'll see this
question on your screen please submit
your answer the question asks what
technology are you currently using to
measure Neuroscience biomarkers so
please take a moment to submit your
answer
again the question what technology are
you currently using to measure
neuroscience biomarkers
great all right well thank you for your
participation I will now pass the
presentation over to Dr tumani
so I hope everything works well and my
camera
and my audio functions also thank you
Kaylee for this nice introduction
thank you UF for your excellent talk
and my part will be now to share with
you the topic on biomarkers biomarker
Research from the perspective of a
clinician of a clinical scientist
clinical neurochemist and a neurologist
um we already
we already heard
okay just a moment
excuse me
so I think this is the correct way okay
you already heard
um what the definition of a biomarker is
and this is here an older one
actually everything in in biology and in
medicine could be a biomarker
and here on the next slide
you see uh what the uses of wire workers
could be
and on this lower figure you see the
different areas
it could be used in pre-clinical stages
to assess at risk population
it could be used at as a diagnostic tool
at the initial clinical onset for early
diagnosis to to define the early stage
of the Seas and also to stratify disease
groups it could be used for
in case of to determine the future cause
of a disease once the diagnosis is
established or to monitor current assist
state
this is more the diagnostic part and it
has also you can use them also in
treatment outcomes
especially if you intend to develop new
treatments and to assess the treatment
response
uh and so uh most important thing where
biomarkers could help us in clinical
routine and and in clinical trials and
then in studies is that
um the biomarker can be uh read
significant readout for in case of
therapeutic intervention before the
clinical endpoint
has reached and the clinical endpoint
could be in in
chronic diseases
it could take very long time we will not
have and to save this time a biomarker
could show the effect of a therapeutic
intervention that's why it might be very
very helpful and in almost all clinical
trials and different kind of diseases
biomarkers are meanwhile
standard readout parameter usually
secondary outcome parameter
here in our
University and and Clinic
as a neurologist we are dealing with
with biomarkers
extensively and to work with biomarkers
you need to have different areas to to
deal with uh not only that the patients
are important
cohorts but also you need to have the
Biomet biosample biomaterial bank
which we talk today about CSF and serum
mainly but there are of course many
other biofluids where biomarkers can can
be looked at
so this is the first what I'm going to
concentrate on
so the basis for biomarker research is
is a very standardized sampling of
defined controls and quality control of
samples and this um
requires Sops which include
at the beginning of the sample
withdrawal whether CSF or or blood
up to
how to do the the lumbar puncture and
all the pre analytical steps the timing
uh and so on and so on this is
summarized in a consensus report which
was published by solo twinison several
years ago and
the same importance also is how to
define the controls
for the diseases you are looking at and
this is also something very important
if you want to show importance of a
biomarker in a specific disease you need
to have appropriate controls to show its
specificity
um and then the bio sample Bank in um it
is important once you collect the
samples that you have of course a
informed consent
for the biomaterials that are of
interest to you and then Define the
chords and controls
and of course include a female typing of
the samples uh not only clinically but
also by Imaging and once the samples
have been collected and uh are
transferred to the to the laboratory
they should be also processed in a
standardized way and this is the way how
we do it here in our Clinic
um
and the biobank software which is in the
database that is that is used
and these are the we use minus 80 up to
minus 150 freezes
with alarm system and of course A
specialized biobank personnel and here
you see our three uh the technical
assistance that take care of the
biosample bank and are very very
devoted to it so now let's talk a little
bit about CSF sample
now usually the CSF sample is taken by a
lumbar puncture as we see in the figure
below here and where does it come from
the the CSF is in the ventricles and in
the lumbar CSF space and
adult usually produces half a litter in
a day and usually 10 to 15 mils or cc is
taken which is can be renewed within
half an hour so it is not a big issue
but it is important to sample enough
volume because the lumbar puncture is
not done that frequently as
as plot
and
so the this the CSF that
we we take by lumbar puncture
comes from the central nervous system
compartment and it is of course
separated within the central nervous
system compartment by by barriers and
two different barriers are there that we
have to distinguish we have the blood
brain barrier and the blood CSF barrier
and here you see in in this blue part of
the figure where the CSF is located and
it is separated by the blood CSF barrier
and
um and the and the blood barrier is only
uh that separates the blood compartment
from the brain parenchyma
so if we take the blood if we take the
CSF then we are we have to deal with the
blood CSF barrier and not with the blood
brain barrier this is important to
distinguish and here in one of our
papers we have summarized what the
anatomical and physiological differences
of this barriers are but in the
literature it's it's
usually mixed up and that's why I'm
mentioning it here
and what is the composition of the CSF
is it the only a brain liquid what uh
the original idea was
if we look at it from the perspective of
proteins
then
our knowledge for today is that 80
percent of the proteins of the CSF are
actually
originating from the blood compartment
so they are able to pass the blood CSF
barrier into the CSF space only 20
percent are originating from the central
nervous system compartment from the from
the brain and the spinal cord and these
20 percent
are made up by coriate Plexus proteins
and only less than one percent of this
brain derived proteins are actually
brain parenchymal
proteins like neurofilaments or gfap or
tall protein but
it is it is a very low concentrated but
the
it was immunoassays at the range of uh
at the diagnostic analytical sensitivity
of
uh of nanogram and picogram you can pick
them up
so um
I told you already that um the CSF
samples and then stream samples require
a phenotypic characterization and this
includes also a neurochemical
characterization neurochemical
phenotyping and whenever we collect a
CSF samples for our biosample bank we
always do a routine CSF analysis which
includes
cytological parameters protein analysis
albumin immunoglobal elements and CSF
and serum oligar formal bands and
depending on the
on the question of the clinician also
pathogen-specific antibodies and also
CMS specific proteins for instance
markers for Alzheimer's dementia and
here there are parameters and at the end
we always try to put all these findings
together into so-called integrated total
result maybe we are able to assess
whether an inflammation is going on what
kind of inflammation what is this CSF
blood CSF barrier
function
about and and so at the end we can more
and or better more reliably do an
interpretation of these results so even
if we have a
question on
[Music]
neurodegenerative diseases like dementia
they always
do use or do conduct this CSF analysis
to rule out other inflammatory diseases
and and from there then to continue to
the uh
positive biomarkers for neurological
diseases
and here
now um
I will talk a bit about the biomarkers
in routine and also uh
about newer biomarkers for neurogenetic
diseases and I will
try to focus here on one a neurological
diseases which uh we um in in our clinic
in our department uh which represents
one main um scientific Focus this is the
ALS amyotrophic lateral sclerosis uh
where
biomarkers can be used to to establish
early diagnosis and to
assess the pro the prognosis of the
disease cause and I will focus here
mainly on the neurofilament and
so what are the the neurofilaments
the neurofilaments are neuron specific
structure proteins that they make up
more than 10 percent of the neural
proteins and here you see a different
subtypes and isoforms five different
subtypes and in routine we usually use
the light chain neurofilaments and the
heavy chain nerve filaments
um
and
now nowadays we use the heavy chain
neurofilaments by Eliza's in the CSF and
the light chain in the blood
so and now uh I will share with you some
data first CSF data of neural filaments
neurof elements I mean are now uh
we are experiencing a real hype uh the
the Publications on neurofilaments have
been
exponentially rising in the past
five years maybe but new filaments are
actually not that new they have been
known for some decades but only they
were detectable in CSR first
and we started to work on neurofilaments
almost 16 17 years ago
at that time using an in-house Eliza
together with Axel petsold and Johannes
bletch Schneider were the first author
of this paper on in ILS we used the
heavy chain
neurofilament and looked at ALS and
Alzheimer's dementia compared to
controls and so that
especially one of these neurogenic
diseases to us at the ILS shows a
significant
higher levels not only compared to the
controls but also compared to the
Alzheimer this is this was a bit of
surprise because two diseases are
neurodegenerative diseases
with the neuronal damage but obviously
the heavy chain neurofilaments represent
only XML damage and that's why they are
typically increased in ALS only and we
looked also
to see whether the progression of the
disease makes a difference on the NF H
level and we saw the patients with rapid
progressions had higher levels than
those of the this low progression
and um
so 10 years later
um
commercially available in license
were there and
also from our Clinic a different group
from Marcos Auto
they're also Stefan Harper is working
with
repeated this
uh the the study was a larger amount of
samples and they saw exactly a could
confirm the results from earlier and
here
they were able to differentiate or to
correlate the level of heavy chain
neurofilaments with the survival time of
the
ALS patients the shorter the survival
time the higher the higher the
neurofilements level were and here you
see on the left the data from the light
chain in the CSF
so the heavy chain was able to separate
better and we were able to define a
cutoff which we still use
in the routine analysis
and so how specific are the requirements
for for ALS is the next question and
actually they are not specific at all
they are a biomarker for neural external
damage but not a biomarker for different
for a special diseases
um and here you see
in this diagram that a different kind of
neurological diseases might be
associated with elevated
neurofelements in CSF and the same is
also true if we look to it into blood
but this is a little bit later but still
there are differences the highest levels
are seen in HIV patients AIDS patients
with cognitive impairment and then
ftld and and ALS but many other digital
diseases are also in the in between also
a mildly elevated and even
inflammatory diseases or immune diseases
like multiple sclerosis may also show
elevated levels and they do correlate
with inflammatory activity and have also
prognostic value which I'm not going to
show here but I will focus more on the
digital scissors on ALS but I just
wanted to show you that the newer
external damage happens in different
kind of diseases independent of the
etiology and here we are sticking on MF
amiotrophic letters closes because this
is the disease was the most extensive
neural Arsenal damage that's why the
neurof laments are here very appropriate
biomarker and now
of course
um the technological
advancement uh
like the inner platform or the similar
platform allowed us now to detect the
neurofelements also in blood we do not
know how the neurofilaments actually get
into the blood we I told you about the
barriers the blood CSF and blood brain
barrier and between the brain and the
CSF there is not a real barrier so
between the excess cellular parenchymal
space and the csfa is not really barrier
that's maybe the explanation why the CSF
has a high concentration and the blood
composition of with neurofilaments
probably uh it might uh it might be
transferred by the bypassing the blood
brain barrier or it might pass the CSF
blood barrier the other way around so we
don't really know exactly but it is
possible to detect it that's the
important way important thing and here
are the different platforms that allow
us to detect
neurofilaments and other CNS specific
biomarkers proteins
at the Phantogram per mil level and how
do the um
data look like if we stay with ALS and
if we measure them in serum not in CSF
and we see it's a
same performance with regard the
sensitivity and specificity and here we
were able also to find the diagnostic
sensitivity of more than 80 percent and
a good specificity so that
serum analysis is enough to get
information about the neural external
damage happening in the central nervous
system so this is so far
so good but how about the reference
ranges what do we use to to report
and are there any
influencing factors that need to be
considered and here we see
very important that the H there is an H
dependency
and these are all reference values and
depending on the age and the upper
values or upper cut off in the H group
up to 18 is
7 picograms but if we are in the age
group of 70 uh the the plasma the cutoff
in the the cutoff will be five times
higher at 35.
so this is uh important to know and to
to report the the reference values
dependent of the age group and a way to
report it is also to use percentiles
curves as reported here by Michelle
Khalil two years ago and another
possibility is also to use a set scores
set scores
is resulting from the standard deviation
of the normal values and here you the
blue ones are the normal ranges the gray
ones are the set scores up to 1.5
and here the other categories that's
cause the yellow ones up to two and the
red ones represent set scores above two
and if you use this kind of reference
range evaluation you see that is of
course of Advantage
as compared to the fixed cut-off values
for instance if you have a 20 years old
patient it's cut off will be uppercut
off will be here around round seven and
the value of 10
which is usually used as a cut off could
be also incorrectly high and for an
older patient a cutoff of 10 could be
falsely low so that's why it's it's
important to to use this way of
reference range and this is now my last
slide so I tried to give you an example
of a red biomarker representative in
case of neurofilaments in a specific
neurological disease and Metric lateral
sclerosis and the wet biomarkers that we
use here almost for several years now in
case of neurofilaments they are well
standardized and easily and cost
effectively
measurable and they already have their
place as endpoints in trials and
different diseases not only in ALS but
also in multiple sclerosis
and in other dementia also
and that's why they are I think very
very helpful for us
I would like to thank you for your
attention and thank the people who do
the work here in our department or
develop biomarkers and to
measure the routine analysis and to take
care of the biosampler bank which you
see here all thank you very much
foreign
thank you Dr tumani what a great
presentation
now before our next speaker is going to
present I'd like to invite the audience
to participate in another poll question
here this question asks what are the top
three biofluid neurological biomarkers
that are the most critical for your
research or work
please submit your question into that
open text box there
again the question asks what are the top
three biofluid neurological biomarkers
that are the most critical for your
research or work
give you a moment to answer this
question
wonderful okay great well with that I
would like to now pass it over to Stefan
to begin his presentation
yeah thank you very much Kaylee for the
nice introduction thank you hireton New
York for your great presentations I will
directly jump in and focus in my part on
the Practical part in the laboratory
from the view of the biomarker developer
and
um you already seen here my first slide
in both of the talks previously so
biomarkers are highly important for
neurological diseases but only not only
not for Diagnostics but also prognostic
staging and here on the right bottom
side I wrote clinical trial so also this
is coming more into Focus as we can now
measure blood
biomarkers using highly sensitive
automated essays this can be then more
important for therapeutic Trials of
effect of drugs on for example any kind
of readout and what kind of
um biomarkers do we have so this is of
course only a selection
um
from Alzheimer's disease we know a total
Tau first foot Tau and the beta peptides
they are used for several use in CSF and
they are more into Focus again now as we
have the techniques also to measure them
in blood but I will more focus on some
other markers some emerging markers but
also the newer filaments which are I
guess not that emerging anymore they are
really used widely I will talk about a
bit how we implemented the
neurofilaments in our Clinic how did we
set up those automated and highly
sensitive essays and then I will also
talk about how do we develop new essays
that we will concentrate on Chief AP and
astrophytic marker and on better side
nuclein presynaptic marker as synaptic
loss seems to be really awesome early
phenomenon in neurodegenerative diseases
and if we have biomarkers for this this
could be highly valuable so
what do we do when we like to implement
or
um yeah establish novel essays so either
we we have knowledge of the disease and
we know what we want to measure or we go
more explorative we have for example
mass pick data we have a lot of
candidates and then we need to
prioritize uh the biomarkers which do we
follow up in a more targeted approach
either with immune essays or also for
example with mrm methods for mass
spectrometry and there are options to
for example really important is to look
at expression profile we can use protein
Atlas DB proteomics to see where's my
protein
expressed but also is it secreted it's a
membrane membrane protein all of that
it's important to know
um before you really dive into the
development or implementation of normal
essays of your proteins and what do we
then do we first of all pay we've
decided on a protein and we check are
there commercial essays available
um yeah because why develop a new essay
if they are good essays out there so
okay yes and first of all still elizas
are the best way to start they are cheap
they can be highly sensitive they're
with us with many years and they have
absolutely their use but you have also
already showed you they have some
downsides like
um they are more prone to human error
for example so we have now
um luckily also more
um automated platforms available I have
three here which hire itinos already
also showed you the similar technique
for quantarix the MSD platform and for
example the Ella platform the simpleplex
Ella and you will hear about that or you
already heard from UF and you will hear
more about that later so
um still now we have an essay available
um commercially available that's great
but still we have to test it and if it's
running and we have to validate it and I
will always get back to this point
validation This is highly important even
if you buy
uh from a provider you trust still
validate the essay in your laboratory in
your surroundings
um this was really important also if you
want to for example really implement
this test uh in the clinic and um
however sometimes there are no essays
available so you can set up your own
essays either you buy commercial
antibodies or you produce your own this
is of course also a question of yeah
economics but both is possible but in
the end you will you need to test those
antibody pairs to set up for example in
Sandwich Eliza but in the end you will
again end up at the validation and where
you really have to validate your essay
if all of this is not working you may
really need to reconsider the technique
and maybe more move to for example a
mass spectrometry technique if you then
have the validated essay you can really
start to deciding you study uh collect
your samples and
measure them so now I want to dive into
those examples I already told you so we
measure the neurof elements in our
clinic in less daily use and of course
we want to measure them in blood
we measure them also in CSF but we also
of course like to see them in Blood and
so what we do at that time
2017-18 of course we looked at other
commercial assets available yes there
were at this time the Seymour was the
first to really have the essay for blood
we chose that and again like I showed
before we tested this essay and did a
full validation law laboratory and and
measured some ALS samples and some other
neurological diseases
um Harrington already showed you this
data we have was a big focus in our
clinic on ALS patients and you can see
this High increase of neurofilament
light in serum in this case so this was
working for the implementation really in
the clinic we had to measure some more
patients to really have a higher number
to set a cutoff between a loss some
controls and then set up a queue system
but hiring also already showed you that
reference values for age dependency are
really important I think the cutoff is
still feasible for ALS versus control so
other levels are so high in ALS but for
other diseases you have to be really
careful and check the age range or have
age reference values
so now um this was actually running
quite good but we wanted to have a maybe
a bit more feasible essay a bit small
benchtop machine which we could use for
the measurement
in our routine and we
yeah Came Upon the Simplex LR system at
that time around two years later and we
tested this essay again we did the full
validation
and measured another big cohort this
time directly also using the nfh
cartridges
and we took a look at the CSF NFL and
nfh and serum levels and again saw this
High increase in ALS patients that was
of course already uh published but
um also the CVS for intra sa variants
and so we're great so we are moved uh to
the Ella platform now where we know uh
daily or weekly measure our new
filaments in the clinic of course we had
to set up a fresh cut off
um to a fresh
um yeah measurement of additional
samples again as we have a completely
different method
um we also done internally compared to
see more method to the Ella NFL this was
never published but you can see on the
left side a bigger Court of a smaller
card on the right side which showing
more or less the same results with them
R of 092 is a really high correlation
between those two essays and UFO already
showed you this publication where the
colleagues showed the same thing in Ms
samples but on the top left corner you
can also already see that the yellow
values and this publication were higher
than the simoa ones so this again puts
the focus on that you really cannot mix
values from the two methods you have to
set up fresh cutoffs also if you of
course move to different platform and
revalidate everything
um so this is how it looks you've seen
that in Austin you have presentations we
use the small benchtop machine I can
also jump over this just again a
reminder in those glass nine Erectors
there's more or less a sandwich essay
um inside and this will be important
um for our homemade
essays which I like to show you now so
you can have the NFL measurements are
done for example in a single Plex
cartridge there are some Multiplex
cartridges but I want to put you focus
here on the right side and this
customizable open cartridge format you
can see there are three Wells now
for one sample and that's this because
you can add yourself of course but then
also capture the detector antibody the
only thing is you have to digoxygenate
your capture antibody and biotinylated
detector antibody and in this way you
can either um test several antibody
combinations or of course up to 48
samples with one antibody combination of
your choice and this is what we used for
a better side nuclein but first maybe a
bit of a background to better signal
clean this is a presynaptic marker
and we more or less have to have to say
stumbled upon this a bit as we were
looking at Alpha Psy nuclein
in Parkinson's disease you can see the
results of this study here this is a
mass pick study on the left side is
Alpha and on the right side gamma sine
and clean and beta cyanoclean we are
more or less just also measured uh the
specific peptides for peptocinating in
this essay and we've seen a high
increase in ad
and so we decided okay this could be
really interesting to follow up and but
before we really moved into developing
immunoassays which of course is also
time consuming and can be expensive we
with the doses of background check and
again as I said we look for example at
the expression profile and you can see
this is data from the protein Atlas web
page you can see there's a high
specificity of beta side nuclein for the
brain for the CNS which is of course
then also really great if you later want
to move to a blood essay so your
concentrations from the CNS more or less
get not mixed up with all the peripheral
expression which is um yeah not there
for better assignment clean
um
so
what did we do now we first of all set
up an Eliza Eliza's as I said can be
highly sensitive and they're of course
cost effective so
um as there was no commercial essay
available we set our own essay we used
commercial antibodies in this case we
bought 10 antibodies and a recombinant
protein we tested different pairs
together to set up a sandwich Eliza and
then we validated this I have now here
the list of validations we mostly do
it's not a fullest but quiet I'd say so
we look for the Matrix effects important
as a parallelism where we dilute CSF
samples or serum samples
you do spike in recovery where you spike
recumbent protein and see how much you
can recover in your Matrix of choice of
course we check the CVS between runs and
within one run we check specificity for
example for
um
Iggs or across reactions Iggs or with
albumin and of course we also look at
the sensitivity and the protein
stability for example after several
freeze and Thor cycles and um
we did this for better cyber clean and
and could publish this uh I would say
nice data on this Elisa with here in the
red uh you can see the ad patients
really highly increased levels in CSF
and
um we now use this antibody combination
and move to a more sensitive platform to
measure it in blood as we did this also
over really uh yeah end of
2019-20 we took again the similar essay
and as I said we could just use our
combination from the Elisa which worked
really great
we coupled it to the beats the capture
antibody which is used in the similar
technique the detector needed to be
biotinylated we tested this and then I
put in the point optimization it's a a
small item here but this is the most of
the work you really need to optimize
your essays if you want to measure them
in blood different buffers different
concentration incubation times
sample preparations and so on and then
again we validated this essay
and we have some nice results uh here on
the right side for example you can see a
polytrauma patients directly in the
emergency room you have a high increase
of plasma better sign to clean which is
dropping over time and then in
comparison to NFL here on the left side
which is rising over time but has not
that steep increase directly after
injury and um
we are now at the moment
um trying to set up an ally essay
um for this and again we can really uh
nicely again use the antibodies from the
Elisa we couple the antibodies to the
DIC oxygen and by a use of biotinylated
detector antibody and we test this run
and then also with the other platform
you have to do some optimizations there
are some buffers provided that you can
check but also the patient or the
concentrations of your antibodies and we
are at this point right now you see the
standard curve looks actually quite okay
but there are some samples outside the
linear range we're still in optimization
phase
um to really set up this essay also on
the Ella platform and my last example
will now focus on gfap it's an
astrocytic marker which is really
increased in
in brain injuries High values for
example in TBI patients but also in ad
and we now there's a small Discovery
essay available but this showed some
variance between runs so you wanted to
set up our own lrsa again we check the
expression profile of gfap and again you
can see there's a high specificity or
for the CNS and
which is of course also done really
great if you want to measure it in Blood
and um yeah I said this here there's
this similar Chief AP Discovery kit and
uh but as I said we are not that happy
with some variances here so we want to
set up our own Lisa we bought some
antibodies again with recombinant
protein we tested this as an in an Elisa
first to find the best antibody
combination in this case we did only a
partial validation because we knew we
wanted to directly move to the Ella
system and for that we took our three
best combinations from the Elisa
um as you can see here now we have the
three Elisa combinations we did the
coupling to the dike oxygen and then the
biotinine and uh tested this and then we
of course needed to select one
combination which works work best and
then we optimized further I wrote The
Star here we did the coating detect and
Sample buffer
um this is second to the antibodies
antibodies are your most important part
of your immunoassay you can optimize as
much as you want with your antibodies
are not showing a good Affinity to your
antigen you will never get a sensitive
essay but buffers can have a high
influence so we always test this first
then
also the concentrations and we look for
example also at the bioaccination ratio
and um then we did the validation and I
have some results for you for the
validation the parallelism results are
not here but we found a nice decrease in
signal and the parallelism so for CSF
and serum we decided on those
um
uh dilutions you see here and we see a
really nice recovery in CSF of 97 and
also great in crmf 85 I would say
between 80 and 120 percent is um highly
acceptable
um the variance was below 10 in the
intra sccv and below 15 in the interest
which is also good and absolutely no
signal
um for human serum albumin or itg which
I think is really important to test
because together they uh account for
around 60 percent of
um
the protein concentrations in Blood of
course finally we also measured a small
cohort you can see here on the left side
CSF uh patients or samples from ad
patients and controls in the same age
range where you have higher values and
also for serum in the middle
um definitely a big difference between
the 80s and the controls
and finally we did a correlation with
the similar essay which as you can see
also correlates really well and with
that I'm also
finished I have a small summary more or
less Four Points to take home if you
really like to go for a new essay set up
here's a really check your protein first
how how is the expression looking like
for example looking the protein Atlas
data
um always validate your essay even if
the provider States this was validated
in here that's that's great of course
and often then that's also working in
your lab but sometimes not so really
validated in your environment and Eliza
is a really good and cheap way to start
developing your essay so you can use
those combinations working in the Eliza
in descent which then and move to the
automated platforms and never forget in
the end the antibodies are the most
important part of your essay and with
this I'd like to really thank the whole
team and
you for your attention thank you very
much
for your presentation and another thank
you to our speakers the rest of them
here let's get them on camera here we go
thank you to all of our speakers here
for your informative presentations
um before we conclude I'd like to invite
the audience to participate in one final
poll question here so I'll get this
displayed would you like a biotechni
immunoassay specialist to follow up with
you so please submit your answer there
and while you're submitting that I'd
like to again thank our speakers for
their time today and their important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor biotechnie for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions as we did
not have time for questions today those
questions submitted during this session
and during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
leverage will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event so until next time take care
everyone goodbye